Let us think through this
a little bit more deeply.
Does the nutritional label make all
the information explicit, David?
>> So it seems like it does, for
each given nutrient in the food,
it lists the explicit amount of that,
that is present in the food.
So it seems like it makes all
the information explicit.
>> Would you say then, it enables me
to draw the right kind of inferences?
Well, it certainly seems like it does.
So, if I'm worried about my diet and
I'm worried about how many
calories I'm consuming,
it tells me right there on the label
exactly how many calories it has.
So, I can infer the right
amount of food to eat per day.
If you're concerned with something
different in your diet, though,
it actually gives you the information
to make a different kind of inference.
>> What about extraneous information,
information that I may not need?
>> Well, that's a good point, actually.
Because it gives the information that
anyone might need and, as a result,
it's going to give information
that's extraneous to somebody.
So, for example,
in my diet, I might not care about
the number of carbohydrates I consume.
So, for me,
that's extraneous information.
But, for somebody else,
that's very important.
So it doesn't avoid
extraneous information, but
it would be really hard for it to do so.
>> What about relationships?
Does it make all the concepts
of all the relationships
between them really explicit?
>> So actually, now that you mention it,
Ashoke, it really doesn't.
So for example, the number of calories
from fat in a particular food is based,
in large part,
on the amount of fat that's in it.
It gives the number of calories from fat
and the amount of fat in it right there
on the label, but it doesn't tell me
that there's a relationship there.
So I really can't make any inferences
based on that relationship.
I don't even know that
relationship exists.
>> So note how this connects with
the ability to make inferences.
Nutritional labels capture some
information that allows us to make
good inferences,
do not capture all the information.